Welcome everybody to our Zoom call today. We had a number of questions that came in. So let's get
right away. I think
Everybody on here has been on for a while, so we'll just jump right to the questions.
We recently purchased a Beiber PEMF device.
You've said the EMF devices are beneficial. Would you please describe what the benefit is?
And in particular, if it is beneficial in cancer prevention.
So I do have a number of web pages on the PEMF
that talk about the benefits of the PEMF and research on PEMF.
You know, that being said, there's really two different types of PEMF devices.
So let's talk about that a little bit here.
And a PEMF device is really measured on the Gauss output. That's the
four civil electrical pulse that's that the machine is putting out. There are two different
types of PEMF devices. A low Gauss PEMF device and a high Gauss PEMF device. So a low Gauss PEMF
device is what the Beiber would fall under. Also, there's other machines on the market. So the Beiber
would be a low pulse, a low Gauss PEMF. The IMRS is another brand on low Gauss PEMF. There's
a number of other ones on the market that are professionally low Gauss output PEMF devices.
A low Gauss output is something you will hardly the impact of it. The pulse of electrical
impulse is going to be very low. You're not going to like feel this giant jolted impulse
into your body. That's what you get with a high Gauss output. So these devices, there's a brand
called pulse. There's a brand called key MF for life. There's lots of other professional brands
that are high Gauss output. It is generally thought in the market that the high Gauss output devices
are more beneficial for serious diseases or injuries. The low Gauss output devices are
more beneficial for life. You don't really have anything serious going on and you just want to
try to stay healthy and you're just trying to help grow yourself and help just balance your
energy. So what's the benefit of PEMF? Well, a couple of different benefits. PEMF does stimulate
to nerves. So it can help decrease inflammation at a site. But that's really mainly only the
high Gauss units. We'll do that. So the high Gauss units can be real beneficial for injuries.
So they would be good for like, you know, you spray your knee. They would be good for, you know,
you hurt your ankle. You pull the muscle. So injuries is, and this is the number one use of PEMF
in our country is high Gauss output PEMF units. I'm talking about professional use like in a clinic
would be high Gauss outputs for musculoskeletal injuries. Very good for injuries because it can help
decrease inflammation. So they're good for that. That's the number one reason why PEMF is used
in a clinical setting is for decrease inflammation to help improve the outcome of injuries,
damage, joints, etc. like that. High Gauss output machines are also going to add charge to
a cell much more rapidly. So I'm talking the difference in numbers here. A low Gauss output
would be a machine that I would define as maybe less than 2,000 Gauss. That's what would be defined
as a low Gauss output machine in my book. High Gauss output machine would be really 2,000 Gauss
to, you know, 40,000 Gauss. So the machine that we used in our office, which had patients come to our
office, was the pulse brand. That's probably the number one brand that another one called Megatronic
brand and it put out about 30 to 35,000 Gauss. Like the beamer puts out 700 Gauss. So that's the
difference. The IFRS is less than 1,000 Gauss. The beamer is about 700 Gauss at its highest setting.
So it's a big difference. What is the difference? It's the amount of electricity that's going through
there. So the benefit of a pulse electromagnetic frequency is the electrical impulse that can help
recharge a cell. So your cell membranes act as a cellular charge, electrical charge for your
body. That's part of what the cell membranes do. And when we get sick, our cell membranes can lose
their charge. That can actually be measured. And that is not a good thing. So using a PEMF can be
helpful for that. Is it specifically helpful for cancer? No, it's specifically helpful just for
overall health. Is a PEMF machine going to kill cancer cells? No, not at all. So it's not a cancer
killing device at all. But increasing your cell charge, will that be better for your immune system?
Will that be better for your detoxification pathways? Will that be better for just cell health?
Well, sure. So indirectly, they're good for anybody regardless whether you have cancer or not.
And if a person already has a beamer, we'll go to say it's use it. But if someone came to me and
said what type of PEMF machine would be best to purchase, I would not say a beamer, I would not say
an IMRS. Now, it wasn't depends on your budget because the higher ghosts output machines cost more.
So the pulse machine that puts out 30 to 35,000 ghosts cost me $38,000. Well, not very many people can
fork out $38,000 for a pulse machine, but a clinic bought that. Now, the one's the PEMF machines
that we sell on our store to patients are relatively would fall into the high ghost output,
but it puts out a maximum of about 6,000 ghosts. Well, those costs like $8,000. They're expensive.
So I don't know how much you paid for your beamer, but you can get an IMRS. I think those are so
you know, knocks through multi-level marketing type things. So I think you can get an IMRS for about
to read $4,000. But I think it's equivalent to the beamer. So I don't know how much you paid for the beamer.
Maybe you got it used and you got a good deal or some friend gave it to you. I have no idea. But those
are low ghost output machines that I don't think they're nearly as beneficial for cancer patients
or somebody with any serious disease or somebody with like peripheral neuropathy. So that's another
really great use of PEMF as if I have peripheral neuropathy from chemotherapy. Well, the PEMF helps
stimulate the nerves and can help heal the nerves so that it can help decrease peripheral
neuropathy symptoms. But the low ghost output machines, they're not going to have nearly the same benefit.
So that's a little spiel on PEMF. Unfortunately, a PEMF, whether it's low ghost output or high ghost
the sales people for these companies steal the research that was done on PEMF. All the research that's
done with PEMF is done with high ghost output machines just so you don't. So all the research that you'll
find in the literature on PEMF and all the benefits are done with high ghost output machines and then
the sales people for the low ghost output machines steal that literature and see see this is what the PEMF
does. Look at all this research. Well, yes, it does, but that's not what a low ghost output machine does.
It's just, it's just the way it is. So I have IDC,
Interductor Carcinoma breast cancer. The past month my breasts have been swallowed at very tender.
My legs are also swallowed and I had hambed for a few years.
Is this indicated my lymphatic system is not draining properly? What can I do to alleviate
the swelling? Lastly, do you have any recommendations for integrative oncologists,
integrative MD in the Twin Cities metro area? Okay, so with swollen legs with
swelling and increased tenderness in the breast, can this be an indication of the lymphatic system
that's radiating properly? Yes, it can be. So what can you do to alleviate these? Well, there's lots of
things. So let's talk about those lots of things. So first of all, what you think about is doing things
that will decrease swelling. So you could run the swelling program on the right. There's also a
program that's called inflammation on the right. So run these right programs there in the
alphabetical listings of the right that you'll find and run those programs. So that's one
thing that you could do. Also, understand the swelling and what it is. You want to do everything
you can to decrease inflammation through nutrition. So different nutrition that will
help with swelling would be the flavonoids. So we're talking aswellia. That's good for that
curcumin. That's good for that. Resveratrol. That's good for swelling. White willow bark.
UGCG from green tea. Extract. That's good for swelling. So anything that will,
don't these are the flavonoids that are also good for pain because so much pain is caused by swelling.
They work for that aswell. So nutrition that can help with that. Also to help with lymphatic detoxification,
you can do lymphatic massages. So if you go to a massage therapist that's trained in cancer therapy
massages, you can get a lymphatic massage. You could also understand that we talked about these the
last couple of zoom calls about when the lymphatic system doesn't have a heart that pumps things
through. So any type of exercises would help with lymphatic detoxification, even just muscle contraction,
getting up, doing some leg razors going up on your toes. If you're sitting down right the
alphabet with your with your toes, just contracting muscles helps with moving limb. So any muscle contraction
is the key. And so anything you could do that involves muscle contraction will help with motion.
So getting up and doing some arm curls, you don't have to do marmels. You just need to do some
little bit of calisthenics. That's going to help move things through. An anti-inflammatory diet can
be helpful, decreasing anything that could be inflammatory. How do we know if it's something that's
inflammatory to me specifically? Well, then you got to think about things that maybe foods that maybe
causing inflammation that you maybe have sensitivity. So you have antibodies to different foods.
How do you know that? You could run a Cyrex test. That would be a Cyrex array 10 panel. Or you could
eliminate the most common things, one of the most common things that are inflammatory foods that would
be gluten, dairy, eggs, think of things like that, meat. Well, I'm already on such a restricted
diet. Okay, well then think of the things above that. So there's a lot of different things that you
could do to help increase the lymphatic detoxification. Work on the liver to hot packs over the liver,
do coffee enemas. Nobody wants to do coffee enemas. Coffee enemas can be really good to help
your detoxify and get things moving. Do I have recommendations for integrative oncologists,
integrative MD in the Twin Cities? I don't, not that's integrative with cancer. There's some natural
MDs in the Twin Cities, but they don't deal with cancer per se. So I don't have any integrative oncologist
ideas. We don't know of anybody personally in the Twin Cities. There's some questions coming
on labs. Would you please comment on healthy cholesterol levels? I'm aware that pharmaceutical companies
keep lowering the numbers to sell statins. Would welcome knowing what you consider healthy levels.
Mine are total cholesterol, 232. So what's a healthy level of cholesterol? Well, according to the pharmaceutical
companies, you need to be less than 200. Some doctors want you less than 180. To me, that's ridiculous.
And I think 200 to 250 is just fine. Benefit cholesterol is a precursor for your vitamin D
formation. 7-hydroxy cholesterol. I think it is this is actually how you make vitamin D from the
sun. The sun will raise your skin. It needs vitamin D and 7-hydroxy cholesterol in the skin in order
to make vitamin D. One of the theories out there is that everybody's reducing their cholesterol levels
with statins. It's actually causing vitamin D deficiency. I think I made that theory up,
but I think it's good theory. So I think it's dangerous to reduce cholesterol too much.
Matter of fact, to lower cholesterol is actually an omitted sign per cancer. So
but if your cholesterol is 232, personally, I wouldn't worry about it.
triglycerides are a little elevated at 107 that speaks to you could have triglycerides
elevated due to hypothyroidism. You could have triglycerides and elevated due to inflammation,
excess inflammation in your body at different things. So there's different reasons why triglycerides
will be elevated. Your LDLs are elevated a little bit. It doesn't mean that you don't look at
you know typically when you have elevated cholesterol and elevated LDLs, to me your first
that is really a first sign of congested liver. Now, if a person has cancer and they have
metastasis to the liver, that could explain some things. But most people, if they get to be 60 years old,
they have a lot of congestion in the liver and different fatty liver disease that has never
been diagnosed. And that is really an issue. So get back to coffee animals and supporting your
liver detox pathways, supporting mild production, all those of the kind of things that you would do.
Hebeoglobin A1C5.8 glucose 78, fasted blood sugar 86. All those are good and with the normal
and it's almost all good. Another blood work question from somebody else, just got my blood work done
and my calcium is low. So what could cause a low calcium? So multiple non-pathological things could
cause low calcium. I breast cancer that is spread to the bone and they want me to increase my calcium
to 1,200 to 1,500 milligrams a day and increase vitamin D to 810,000. I use per day. What brands
do you suggest? First of all, I would not. So if I had metastasis to the bone and low calcium,
Personally, I would take excess calcium.
I would not take 1,200 to 1,500 milligrams a day.
Benefact, there's a multiple studies out that shows
that when they started recommending 1,500 milligrams a day
to women back in the late 70s and 80s,
heart disease went through the roof in women
and it was due to calcification plaque
and other arteries causing stiff arteries
that increase blood pressure and cardiovascular disease.
So taking too much calcium can be dangerous.
I think stayed below 1,000 milligrams a day
of calcium is important.
Also, you need to make sure that you're not taking
the wrong type of calcium.
Most calcium out there is calcium carbonate
and that is literally limestone.
So limestone is found in the earth.
It's found in the soil and it's easy to wash and capsilize
and sell it as a calcium supplement
and calcium carbonate does not absorb in your body.
You hope it's not absorbing, it does not absorb well
and what is absorbed can relate out in your arteries
and will laid out in your ligaments
and cause arthritis first.
Calcium carbonate is not what you want to take.
The only type of calcium, the only type of minerals
that you want to take is our minerals that are
keylated the way.
So calcium carbonate is a keylation.
So calcium is keylated to carbonate C-O3
or something I can remember.
And that's how it's found in nature.
Plants take calcium carbonate
and they actually change it to calcium lactate
or calcium that's double bonded to a amino acid.
So either you take a,
so you want to take a calcium that's keylated
as it would be found in nature.
And in nature I mean the way we're supposed to eat it.
So we're supposed to eat plants.
We're not supposed to eat dirt.
So we eat plants.
Plants take calcium carbonate,
they change it to calcium lactate
and calcium double bonded by it's called dysglicinate.
So it's typically that would be a double bonded to glycine
but it could be double bonded to other amino acids too.
When you have a mineral that's double bonded
to an amino acid that carries it across the gut border
very easily and gets it into the cell.
You need your minerals to get inside the cell
to do their work.
So the cells can use them.
You don't want minerals not able to get inside the cells
that just cause,
that just act like almost like a heavy metal toxicity.
And that's where if you eat minerals,
if you take minerals in a elemental form like that,
you cause damage.
That's why I'm not a fan of those liquid elemental minerals.
That's not how we're supposed to take minerals.
And the same thing with,
you see that a lot with iodine is very similar.
Typically sold in a very poor form.
So you want to take minerals that are keylated
with a double bond to an amino acid.
And there's only a couple of companies that make that way.
And those are listed as albiode minerals.
And tracks, I think it's spelled that way, minerals.
They, these companies do not sell directly.
So these are supplement companies.
These are paired companies,
you could say have supplements,
that then sell to supplement companies.
So supplement, if you look at the back of the supplement,
and it says calcium, potassium, magnesium,
and then down below it says,
a tracks or albiode mineral patented by albiode and tracks.
Then you know it's a really good supplement
because these are double bonded as the same way
they'd be found in nature to an amino acid
so your body can use them.
These are the only minerals that you want to take
are the albiode and tracks.
All the companies that we have private labeled
use albiode and tracks.
So I personally wouldn't take in the case
if this was me and I had low calcium
and I had metastasis in the mode,
I would only take the clear multivide plus
that's our Connor's clinic private labeled multi-mins.
It doesn't have excess amount of calcium.
It has a good balance in minerals
the way you'd find it in nature.
It's all albiode and tracks bound, double bonded
amino acid minerals so that you'll use it
just like your eating really good plants.
That's the way you want your minerals.
Your vitamin D, you could get the vitamin D in the ADK
that we have so the ADK complete is got vitamin D,
5,000 I use and ADK and that is all your fat soluble vitamins
in one of their some benefits to getting all your fat soluble
vitamins in one thing.
So if you took two of those a day,
you'd have plenty of vitamin D.
My alkaline phosphatase that's alkaline phosphatase
blood work was higher than two weeks ago
even after my infusion.
So your infusion will not typically reduce alkaline phosphatase
levels, alkaline phosphatase is produced by your liver
so it can be due to liver congestion
but it's also produced if there's a bony
leadic destruction of bode in the case
of metastasis to the bode.
So if the alkaline phosphatase is elevated,
it's due to the metastasis to the bode.
It's not, it typically will not be reduced through,
it's not going to infusion to increase your hemoglobin
it's not going to help with your alkaline phosphatase levels.
So the other thing I want to speak to this
that I'm going to erase this in order to have space for it
is if you have metastasis in the bode,
you really should be on TVGO.
TVGO is a brand is US enzymes brand
and if I could private label it, I would US enzymes
brand of green T extract.
So the the Catechid in green T extract
that's so important is the EG CG,
that's how it's supposed to be written like that.
That's a Catechid in green T extract
that is decreases and is one of the only things
that has been shown to decrease the interleukin,
six, which is an inflammatory cytokine
that's found at the surface of the bode,
especially when there's a lytic destruction of the bode.
So it's at the surface of the bode
where there's lytic destruction.
It's an inflammatory cytokine
and it is you want to decrease the level of IL-6 at the bode.
And EG CG will do that.
I used to say it was the only thing that was discovered.
They actually did some new research
and they found that it also acted in the same way.
Curcumin much less.
EG CG from green T extract and resveratrol,
both decrease IL-6 at the surface of the bode.
So when there's either a lytic destruction of the bode
or even osteoporosis,
you really the treatment in your first think of,
oh, I have osteoporosis
or I have lytic destruction of the bode.
I need to increase my calcium right away
and increase the vitamin D.
Well, really the first thing you need to increase
is you need to increase the things that will decrease
the interleukin six at the surface of the bode,
which is EG CG and resveratrol.
We have several resveratrols.
We only carry good resveratrols.
We have multiple different resveratrols on our store.
So I like the resveratrol plus,
and we privately label it from designs for health
and it's a great product.
But that's definitely you want to be out of that.
And the reason why I'm talking about the TV
or the U.S.N.
Zimes is green T extract is the most polluted nutrient
across the whole supplements world.
So all the supplements that exist on planet earth,
green T extract is the most polluted with pesticides.
And U.S.N. Zimes is the most anal company
with looking at green T extract.
I like a lot of different supplement companies
but U.S.N. Zimes is the most pure, especially
for green T extract.
So that's the only one I really recognize the TV goal.
And you should really take about three of these a day,
certainly super high dosage.
And the resveratrol plus, you will really want
about three a day of each one of these.
But you do have to spread them out
because the half life on resveratrols, very short,
green T extract, the EG CG is a little bit higher
but those veratrols, very short.
So you need to spread them out through the day.
That will be the best thing to decrease the inflammation
of the bone to help you uptake any nutrients that you have.
Certainly you want the right calcium.
You don't need excess calcium.
You certainly want vitamin D,
but you need to decrease the inflammation.
I am planning traveling over Christmas to Puerto Rico.
Hey, if you are going to go to Puerto Rico,
you really need to bring me with just to check out the place
that sounds like a wonderful retreat.
I have never traveled via airlines with my right.
Any tips on travel I have reluctant to check my right
because baggage for fear of damage
even though the travel case is fairly robust.
So what I have traveled with my right a lot,
anytime I went on a seminar, any time I went anywhere
I always brought my right with.
And I'll be honest, I don't have a hard case.
So I never brought it with a hard case.
I think you don't have to worry at all
if you're going to bring your hard case.
My only fear in, I just wrapped it in a sweatshirt
in my suitcase.
My only fear was what if they lose my suitcase?
It really wasn't a fear that it was going to get damaged.
I wrapped it in a sweatshirt and wrapped that in another shirt.
So I didn't feel like it was going to get shook enough too much.
I feared that they were going to lose my suitcase.
So then I started just putting it in my carry on.
If you're going to bring your carry on
as the plastic case that the right came in,
then you have to worry about it at all.
Going through the TSA though, they will ask you what it is.
You can just say it's a right machine,
it's a light frequency machine.
It's going to go through X, right?
They're going to see it's not a bomb.
They're going to look at you weird, but you know,
I've gotten, every time I bring it as a carry on,
they I get pulled over.
So plan on a few extra minutes
because they're going to pull your bag off
and you're going to have to, you know,
they're going to look through it and do a swab test
to make sure there's no bomb substance or something.
And they're going to ask you, you know,
I've had people not ask me what it is at all.
They just said it, you know, just sometimes they're not very friendly.
The last time I went, they said,
what is this?
I said, it's a right machine.
It's a light therapy machine.
And he, he like whatever, I'm sure they get tons of stuff.
They think that people are just weird, you know,
sure they thought that of me.
So I wouldn't be worried about it.
My only concern with traveling with the right
is what if they lose my bag.
Now all the years I've traveled, I've never had a bag loss.
My wife did, but we did get her bag the next day.
But I've heard of people that didn't have their bag
for the whole vacation, you know,
so that you don't have your right for the whole vacation.
That would be my concern.
So my hemoglobin is a bit low.
And the oncologist recommend doing an iron infusion
as I am currently doing a low dose chemo pump.
And there's a chance it could drop even more.
I do not want the infusion.
What supplement would you recommend instead?
Also, I have not received the result
in full genetic report as it did not come through either email.
Thank you.
Okay, I didn't read this question.
Unfortunately, I don't read these questions before I actually
am talking to you right now.
So I will have to look back and see who sent this
and get you yourself a main report or the genetic report.
The genetic report is like 250 pages down.
Sometimes it doesn't end up attaching.
So if you didn't get it just let us know.
So if your hemoglobin is low enough
that they would recommend an iron infusion.
It's probably below eight.
Nothing supplement wise.
It's going to raise your hemoglobin faster
than doing an infusion.
So I personally would do the infusion if it was me.
That's going to raise your hemoglobin up.
That's going to actually make you feel better.
Give you more energy.
You're going to feel a lot better and be safer.
If you're going to just take iron
and do the artimicited program,
it's going to be very slow raising your hemoglobin.
You can do that as well,
but I personally would do the infusion.
And if you're like set against it,
you don't feel like you're led to do that.
Then I would use our iron emissited program
and the iron that we use is called clear iron.
It's our product and or reacted iron
or reacted iron, the author of the molecular product.
Or the designs for health has an iron, say,
it's the exact same thing.
The beverage, it's a tracks product from the good products
where it was that is the albeda tracks.
So the good supplements are using,
good supplement companies are using literally
the exact same base substance.
Maybe I put other things in it,
but it's still the iron itself,
the mineral itself is going to be tracks or albeda.
Okay, some questions on the chat here.
We're going to the way back a lot of questions.
You have my rife set for each night.
If I use it earlier in the day,
do I do it again that night for the same day
or move out of the next?
No, I would just do it again.
Just do it again, otherwise you'll get all that stuff.
Also, should I be using my grounded pad with it?
No, so you use your grounded pad with the iron pro wing.
We haven't run out of YouTube video.
The guy says to use the grounded pad,
we were told to use grounded pad for the 40 tonks.
That's correct.
Just use it for the 40 talks.
Do not use it when you're doing your overnight set.
How do you know which influenza to use
if there's somebody to choose from on the rife?
There wasn't a setting for 2022.
That's correct.
You realize that in any given year,
there are nearly 1,000 influenza
that are circulating through society,
ridiculousness of getting a flu shot.
They can only guess on which one is going to be the most virulent.
And they can only get about three different varieties
in the flu shot.
What you're going to be exposed to 1,000 varieties
are in influenza.
Are you kidding?
The flu shot is not effective.
Stagiarist, you should not be getting flu shots.
Okay, this will go out to the public.
I'm just giving you my opinion.
You're still getting vaccinated with the information
that's out there.
You really need to educate yourself.
That's my opinion.
You can throw it out all you want.
You can probably acquire it.
I consider that a compliment.
But I have not a pro vaccine with all the edge amongst
that there are 20 vaccines
and what the damaging things that that's doing to your body.
How do you know which rife program to use?
You just got to try them and see which one seems to help you.
There's no perfect way to know you can't.
So just try the different influenza programs.
You feel like you're coming down with the flu,
do the cold and flu on-cunning,
do the different influenza programs.
You're just going to have to run through that.
Same with your bacterial programs.
Oh, there's, I feel like I got a strep throat.
I got a sore throat.
There's a whole bunch of strep programs.
You just have to run some of them, just run them.
They're frequencies that they are hitting the right thing.
They're going to have benefits.
So just try them.
Does bedbed is all go after red blood cells?
I'm also on an oral chemo, chemo,
which is really good at killing them.
My levels are low and try to find ways to boost it.
Blood transfusion has been discussed
but not excited with that choice.
Typically good blood transfusion,
your hemoglobin has to be below eight
some clinics, hospitals,
require you to have a hemoglobin below 7.5
before they'll even allow you to do blood transfusion.
So if you're hovering at 8.5 or nine,
you've got to even be in the catapult.
From what I have read,
I have not read anything that bedbed is all damages red blood cells
so I don't think that's causing any of the issues.
Certainly chemo does.
If your hemoglobin is above eight
and they're not even talking about a transfusion at this point
because you don't fit into that category,
look at the iron artimisticate protocol on our blog.
That's usually iron with artimisticate together
because the issue with taking iron
is iron can be a feeder of cancer.
So if it's good if the cancer is going to double it up
and we want it to gobble up artimisticate at the same time
which could help kill cancer.
I just read about some recent research
about combating alpha-lapagacid in artimisticate
to help kill cancer if you've heard about this.
There's a lot of research about
lots of different supplements in cancer.
So yeah, there's tons of stuff about artimisticate
and tons of alpha-lapagacid is highly,
it's probably one of your stronger anti-oxidants
and can be very beneficial too.
The only thing with alpha-lapagacid is
that if you're doing chemotherapy,
you really can at least be an 48 hour window after chemo,
you can't be an alpha-lapagacid
but it's such a strong antioxidant.
Yeah, artimisticate is not.
Artimisticate is mainly anti-fogo,
anti-birol, anti-bacterial.
You can certainly do that.
It's certainly worth a try.
I had the calcium question.
They had the Zylbeta.
That is one that calcium is low.
But okay, like I'm just,
so that's the cause of the low calcium.
Still, I would not,
I'd still follow those recommendations that I could be.
What's your thoughts on cysteine be the cause
of my pancreatic cancer as I pulled the kidney stones?
I read where they were starving this type of cancer
with cysteinease, which breaks down the cysteine in the water.
Well, that's interesting.
I haven't seen that,
so I'd be open to looking at that
and to have any of those research articles
feel free to email me and appreciate that.
Cysteine is in amino acid.
Cysteinease is a protein that,
excuse me, may enzyme that breaks down cysteine,
but maybe that's one of the reasons why high dose sun enzymes
can be so good for pancreatic cancer, liver cancer,
intestinal cancers.
So, good comment.
So, I think, first I'd ask that question.
We do have you on some higher dose.
They're just events, I'm stupid.
My functional doctor reviewed my Dutch test results,
he ordered her test for me.
You both noted my low levels of bad estrogen.
Okay, he noted my poor results on methylation.
He wanted me to supplement to help with that,
but I know you say no to methylated things.
What do you suggest to support methylation pathways
when poor results on the Dutch test?
So, just because you have poor methylated estrogens
does not mean that you actually have a methylation problem.
Just because they're low methylated estrogens.
So, that's not really the negative of methylation problem.
Where I would say your key thing
with a methylated problem as far as any tested,
objective tested is your, if you do a complete blood count
in a comprehensive metabolic panel would be homocysteed.
Homocysteed is your made thing
that you'd look at for having a methylation problem.
So, homocysteed is, if that's elevated,
then we do, and your cancer is relatively under control,
then do we talk about adding methylated nutrition?
Because if your homocysteed is within normal range
and you have cancer, even if you don't have cancer.
So, let's pretend you don't have cancer.
Your homocysteed is within normal range
and you went and did a genetic test
and you have an MTHFR gene defect.
So, MTHFR is methyl tetrahedral folate,
reductase gene.
That's the gene defect that most functional doctors will go,
oh my gosh, we need to get you a methyl tetrahedral folate.
All right, away we're gonna put you on MTHFR
for the folate.
We're gonna get you a methyl B12.
So, methyl comolamine because you have an MTHFR gene defect.
Well, first of all, just because you have a gene defect
doesn't mean that that gene is not working
and how can you tell if that gene is not working?
But you can look at other lab work.
You might look at, in this case,
with an MTHFR gene defect, you wanna look at homocysteed.
If your homocysteed is elevated,
then you do need methyl groups.
You do need some B vitamins and you do need some methylation.
If you take methyl groups and you don't have cancer at all,
you take excess methyl groups and you have too many methyl groups,
it pushes another pathway called your biopterum pathway,
which is the pathway, that of other pathway
where you make all your neural transmitters.
And you will make excess amounts of serotonin and dopamine.
And dopamine issues, you can become very addicted
to dopamine, right?
And serotonin issues in excess can make you
literally kind of go crazy.
So you could have these spurts of serotonin.
You think serotonin is the happy neurotransmitter.
Only when it's a balanced excess serotonin can cause
rage issues, especially if you have any defects on that pathway.
So I'm not in favor, I'm looking at one test and diagnosing that.
Certainly I'm looking at methylated estrogens.
It does not mean if you have low amounts as I need methyl groups.
Secondly, this is my opinion, if it's your own own if you want.
But secondly, excess methyl groups,
but methyl groups do, they silence genes
and they can turn off other genes
and you can end up with other issues.
You certainly do not want to be turned it off
to their suppressor genes.
You need to be activating those as much as possible
if you have a cancer diagnosis, really.
But if you don't have cancer diagnosis,
so most of our cancer patients are eating better,
they're eating greens, they're eating, you know,
salads, they're eating better nutrition,
they're getting plenty of naturally occurring methyl groups.
So I wouldn't worry about that.
The only time that I Trump not a cancer patient
not doing taking methyl groups
is if they have elevated homocysteine.
So if you have elevated homocysteine,
then we need to add some more methyl groups
to your diet to lower those homocysteine levels.
To help detox catalyticium,
he suggests two times a week EDTA IV twice per week
with a few weeks following MRI.
Your thoughts on this?
Well, EDTA is one of your,
is really your strong, the strongest key later in my book.
So key laders are, in my book are the students,
mild, moderate, and strong key laders.
Remember, chelation is the part of detoxification
that I call phase zero detoxification.
You have to make sure that phase one, two, three, four, five,
six are working really healthfully.
And most of our patients are already working on all those things.
That's part of what you're doing.
So you probably could do EDTA chelation.
Couple caveats to that.
Do you have any mercury fillings?
Well, the answer to that is yes,
then you absolutely better not be doing EDTA IV chelation.
That's just crossed out the list.
No.
And so there are some negatives to it.
I am not a great big fan of IV chelation
because EDTA is such a strong key later.
It's been proud to actually key like the plastic
out of the bag that it's found in the chelation bag
and can cause plastic issues.
So I'm not a big fan of EDTA chelation,
but that's just my opinion.
Personally, if I had acute arsenic toxicity,
absolutely take IV EDTA chelation.
But that's just going to be a personal choice.
I'm not completely against it.
If you have any metals in your body,
if you have the nickel plate of your jaw,
if you have mercury fillings in your teeth,
you do not ever do any EDTA IV chelation.
But do you think of zeolite to help detox catalyticium?
Absolutely.
Zeolite is a moderate chelator.
You can do that either with mercury fillings.
Zeolite is a great chelator and a binder
could actually have actually a binder too.
So it's great.
I take buffered vitamin C powder from per cancellations,
which is calcium escorbate.
Is that a bad idea?
No, I don't know what the milligrams of that
is I have to look that up.
There's a magnesium escorbate
and a potassium escorbate too.
I think that's just that buffered agents.
So it's not like you're taking it for the calcium
or for the magnesium that's buffered and in your stomach.
So the idea of a buffered vitamin C is
it's vitamin C can be irritating to your stomach.
It's acidic, it's a scorbic acid
and it can just be irritating to a person's stomach.
So buffered it with some minerals helps call that,
helps you absorb it better.
In this case, you're not taking it
and these minerals are to the high dose
where you're getting a poor source of minerals.
So I think that's just fine.
I also take pure encapsulations,
magnesium, citrate, malactyl.
I think pure encapsulations uses albion attract minerals
in their minerals.
I think you're fine with that.
How many clear multiband plus do I take
if I were you?
Cause you asked the question about,
I would take four a day and those.
How do we get a new insert for our right cases?
I have traveled with it so much
the bottom piece is getting kind of ready and torriddled.
I need to replace it the next few months.
Do I contact true right?
Yes, I would contact true right for this.
And by the way, true right is updating their websites.
So if you go to look up search true right,
their website is actually down completely
because they're doing a whole re-update on their website.
It might take a couple days for them to get done
and we contacted them today.
So they said it might not be till tomorrow night
or Friday before their website is up.
So don't think that they folded or something like that.
I got an email from true right,
but I think it said that there was a new update maybe.
So there may be a 2022 update.
But again, they're true right.
We're discussing on the frequencies
that are going to be valuable,
but it doesn't mean that those are going to be
the specific frequencies of the virus
that you're exposed to forever.
I said there's like a thousand at the end of the year
that are right around in society.
Is it better to rub black seed oil on my skin near my pancreas
or to ingest it?
Well, you're not going to absorb a lot of black seed oil
through your skin.
So definitely ingesting it would be a better way
to get that for sure.
In the store, the designs for health repair at all
is supreme not plus.
I think our private label is plus.
So yeah, use the Resvera Troll Supreme
from your leg for health.
That is a good one.
The Resvera Trolls from Ortho Molecular is a good one too.
So that is a good product too.
Let's refer okay.
All right.
I'm not getting great at folding my coffee
animal for the recommended time frame.
Does this get better through practice?
Am I still getting some benefit,
even though I'm not following it as recommended?
You're recommending it.
Go back to the member site.
I think it's the home page or one of the,
maybe it's on the call, I don't know,
remember what page I put it on,
but I created the easy piece of coffee
animal protocol and you could follow that.
It is not essential that you hold it
for any recommended time frame.
Even if you're able to hold it for 30 seconds,
you're still getting some benefits.
Remember the main purpose,
you're doing the coffee animals
to stimulate parasympathetics and doing it
and you're only holding it for, you know, 25 seconds,
you're still getting benefit of doing the coffee animal.
So don't beat yourself up, up, up, up.
Any news on the Navarro?
Somebody told me last week that they tried to order it
and they still were not accepting orders.
You mentioned that you have to just try some
of the right programs that come with the right.
Does the scanner have help with that figure?
No, not really, no, because you have to get
really good at doing the scanner
and it's not, it's still, it's far from perfect.
And I actually developed the thing that right
uses right now for their skating,
but I'm still far from a fan of thinking
that you're gonna get the exact frequencies through skating.
So there's an art to it and I wouldn't,
I would just use some, let's say if I had,
you know, felt like I was coming down with something,
I would be running the viral complex program.
You could run the cold and flu on coming programs,
some of the flu programs dealing with a sore throat
that I'd be running those programs, for sure.
If you do some of the overnight programs,
you're gonna be hitting major frequencies
that are gonna be helpful.
I deal with the edema.
I do a cup of warm water first,
hold it until I need to go.
Then I do the coffee edema at helps a lot.
A lot of people do kind of a pre edema
before they're coffee edema.
To kind of clean out themselves a little bit
and then they can hold the coffee edema a little bit better.
Sometimes that can really help with people.
So trying some of those things can be really beneficial.
That's the wonderful thing about this group
is that we get these comments
and you can learn from them.
Having to be on first does cut down on the cramping, yes.
Where else can you be in a group
where we're talking about coffee animals like this, right?
Some people are thinking, where else would you want
to be in a group that's talking about coffee animals like this?
We're just that kind of people, yes.
Warm water plus coconut oil for pre edema.
Ooh, that's a good one.
Okay, thank you for that.
That's good.
Coconut oil can be very soothing to the cut too.
All right, it's made about an hour.
So I think we'll bid everybody a do.
No, then I'll be praying for all you guys.
I love you all.
Thank you for being a part of this group
and supporting each other, praying for each other
and just wanting the best for everybody.
I want to see you guys on Monday, bye.